des kilomètres et des kilomètres de
boisé calciné et des infrastructures
parties en fumée
c'était comme si j'étais en enferile le
brasier ici est toujours en activité son
équipe et lui en plus d'éteindre les
flammes gère les installations
tout pour le garder occupé pour éviter
de penser à ce qui lui est arrivé
les flammes ont eu raison de sa maison
voisine pour la sauver et il a vu les
flammes sortir d'une fenêtre de son
domicile
le feu est venu d'ici et s'est rendu
jusqu'à sa maison affirmée
juste à côté sont en gare avec tout son
équipement de pêche a aussi disparu
j'ai construit mon entreprise de pêche
en disant si j'ai réussi à l'époque je
le referai maintenant
[Musique]
c'est que mes filles et ma femme soient
que les ressources étaient insuffisantes
pour combattre les feux heureusement
selon lui qu'il y a des pompiers
volontaires
autant que vous le pouvez à vos pompiers
volontaires afin qu'ils puissent se
munir d'équipement
ici dans ce qu'il appelle son coin de
paradis ici Élisa serrer Radio-Canada